il a par l'état notre collègue jean
baptiste lemoyne pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci beaucoup monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des finances y lire
vous présentiez le dernier budget du
quinquennat que vous pourrez exécuté en
totalité
l'année prochaine le budget 2010 est
sera nécessairement amendé par celui ou
celle qui sera amené à redresser la
france est désignée par les français
mais déjà ou plutôt encore vous tirer
des chèques en blanc que dis-je des
chèques en bois et je veux prendre deux
exemples les impôts et la fonction
publique les impôts vous annoncer 2
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
pour les ménages
vaste blague quand on sait que depuis
2012 vous avez manier l'assommoir
fiscale avec entrain 55 impôt créé ou
augmenter des dizaines de milliards
d'euros pris sur pouvoir d'achat des
ménages en trois ans comment
financez-vous ces baisses d'impôt nous
on le sait tout simplement en faisant
les poches des collectivités locales et
vous savez que et bien des tréfonds de
la france ça gronde parce que le 19
septembre dernier à l'initiative de
notre collègue françois baroin des
maires de toutes obédiences politiques
d'ailleurs ont manifesté et vous savez
que ce sont des gens qui sont
républicains et qui sont les piliers de
la république
alors si le ras-le-bol gagne il faut il
faut l'entendre ensuite sur la fonction
publique
vous annoncez ainsi aux fonctionnaires
que vous voulez les augmenter tenez vous
bien entre eux mi 2017 et 2020 la
ficelle est un peu grosse
vous aurez sûrement quitter les affaires
en tous les cas on y travaille et vous
et c'est l'héritage de successeur alors
en plus vous asseyez sur la démocratie
sociale comme emmanuel macron s'assied
sur la démocratie politique ont entendu
ces propos alors monsieur le ministre
plutôt que le miroir aux alouettes quand
prendrez-vous enfin les décisions
structurelles qui s'imposent pour me
répondre la parole est au ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur
en matière de fiscalité vous avez parlé
de blague la réalité c'est qu'il y à 12
millions de français qui ont une baisse
des impôts en 2016 sur les 18 millions
de foyers fiscaux et la véritable blague
monsieur le sénateur c'est de savoir
comment il serait possible cela avec les
100 milliards
lorsque vous parlez des collectivités
territoriales avec les 100 milliards de
baisses de dépenses publiques que votre
formation politique propose le jour où
nous aurait expliqué ça vous pourrez
effectivement avoir un peu plus de
sérieux sur ces questions et puisque
vous avez abordé un sujet qui est
extrêmement sérieux qui est celui de la
réforme de la fonction publique et de la
carrière des fonctionnaires
je vous y répondre très précisément
parce qu'effectivement au bout d'un an
de négociations avec les neuf
organisations syndicales nous avons fait
des propositions qui simplifie et
modernise le statut des fonctionnels
pourquoi parce que la vie prend la vie
professionnelle
évidemment s'allonge parce qu'on a
laissé progressivement se détériorer les
niveaux de réduire de rémunération à
l'embauché
parce qu'il faut résorber des inégalités
et notamment les inégalités hommes
femmes
parce qu'enfin il ya trop de rigidité
aujourd'hui dans la fonction publique il
faut faciliter la mobilité
six syndicats sur neuf monsieur le
sénateur ont signé cet accord et donc
nous nous retrouvions dans une situation
une inédite à vrai dire où il y avait
50% des salariés représentés des
fonctionnaires représente et qui
souhaitaient cet accord et 50% qu'il ne
le souhaitait pas nous avons pris nos
responsabilités parce que ce
gouvernement ne cesse de réformes et
nous voulons que ce progrès longuement
négocié ne soit pas bloqué par le refus
de s'engager de certains vous le savez
et pourtant vous allez là l'air de
prenez le contraire monsieur le sénateur
l'immobilisme n'est pas possible parce
que nous c'est bon pour le pays parce
que c'est bon pour le les fonctionnaires
nous avons décidé d'appliquer cette
réforme
l'homme a piste lemoine pour répliquer
côté monsieur le ministre les faits sont
têtus et les chiffres sont les chiffres
comme deux et deux font quatre
l'abaissement du plafond du quotient
familial ces deux milliards d'euros qui
était pris aux ménages la fin de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
milliards d'euros donc ça c'est du
concret et puis s'agissant de la
fonction publique la différence entre
vous et nous c'est que vous créez 8000
postes supplémentaires cette année nous
c'est vrai il y avait moins de
fonctionnaires mais nous souhaitions
qu'il soit admis qu'ils soient liés
qu'ils soient mieux rémunérées voilà
c'est la feuille de route pour nous
merci mon cher collègue